this is the site of the German capital
that everyone knows the Reichstag Cory
burst and the Brandenburg Gate but
there's a lot more to Berlin than its
tourist attractions tourists willing to
jump on a bike can discover a
lesser-known but no less exciting aspect
of the city
the idea of peck fine is to take
visitors on a culinary tour of the
German capital Berlin subbaiah become
frozen Alliance famous switch thriving
art scene but what a lot of people don't
know is that it's also home to a lively
food scene of an accordion are
acoustically for example its many small
companies that produce handmade
specialties even local residents are
intrigued yep Tevez often I have
visitors in town and we thought this
would be interesting I be the ambit we
buy my cancel the ultimate feeling it's
about seeing things made with love by
people who really believe in what they
do between phone and I to cancel yeah
it's good to see another side of Berlin
not just the usual sites everyone knows
the first stop on today's itinerary is a
bakery where everything's done the
old-fashioned way
most people on the tour have never
actually seen how bread is made
and many had no idea how many different
types of bread there actually are from
spelt croissants to wholemeal loaves and
wedding cakes everything here is made
with the finest ingredients and the
utmost care
the tour goes off the beaten track and
takes participants in two parts of town
that don't necessarily feature in the
usual guidebooks the tour guides are
happy to throw in a bit of background
and they also provide historical context
where necessary ed masley the boy
Justine on to thank my thoughts Berlin
is an increasingly popular tourist
destination there's a lot to see and do
and a variety of ways to explore the
city jogging through it for example
or strolling through the historic
Nikolai fiddle with a night watchman
some places which time seems to have
forgotten can only be visited as part of
a guided tour but back to our foodies
well in vic want is none we want to get
away from mass-produced stuff we think
food should have a personal touch and
you should know who made it this british
cafe is just the sort of place he likes
my mum bikes a lot so I always grew up
with a lot of baking I grew up on a farm
my dad had a Dairy Herd so we used to
actually make the cream like we serve
here when I was a kid katy hudson and
her husband started the business in 2011
what we're serving is traditional
english scotland's they gave up jobs in
engineering and marketing to set up the
cafe and they've been keeping their
customers satisfied ever since the pec
fine tour costs 30 euros per person and
it lasts for five hours Falco Schumann
makes jams and condiments and he likes
to experiment with unusual ingredients
like white poppy seeds on one condition
the ingredients must be all-natural
so what's the verdict this team for
great group first time better it was fun
seeing the city by bike not the usual
way I get around patna the fish buscalo
trans antis it was very interesting I
bought a lot too it was fun yeah that's
awesome water and everybody gets to take
home a few souvenirs from Berlin and
they get to enjoy some great food
you